[Music]
joe and adam
you two men are the non-non-married men
in the room
oh yeah it's raining man would you
prefer i call you a boy
no man is completely accurate i like
unmarried man become a
man when you get married but men
plural how about children
children so you two children just
kidding no so imagine you guys go
to a wedding and you're at this
wedding and then all of a sudden the
groom
doesn't show up and so then the bride is
like
what the [ __ ] and then the bride's
family is like what the [ __ ]
we need to marry this [ __ ] and then
they just pluck you out of the audience
what country hey you down and marry this
chick how hot is she though
how much no that's cause if she's hot
then i'd be like
we'll get a divorce after and then you
know
it's very like rude to think like just
to marry her
based on how she looks you gotta ask
like how much money she has
a question about the person like i like
that he's he's down to earth what kind
of shows does she like to watch
in the spare time because she doesn't
know because if she's an orange is the
new black chicken i gotta sit there with
her i can't i don't know if i can
i don't know i don't know yeah but if
she's 90 data
90 day fiance i'm like oh my god this
was meant to be
or 90 day the other way if she's a more
the other way chick i can have anything
with that
yeah that's true and where am i at with
my life you know am i like
broke doing jk news or am i like yeah
yeah you're broke dude
no things are better you've left you've
left that no you're the
one
yeah so you guys think you'd be down
again it
depends we have a picture of her so we
can tell her personality yeah man
that's the important thing all right
well what's the looks that count okay
did she do her nails that day
before i show you the photo i'll tell
you the story okay so this takes place
in india i don't know how guys work
this takes place in india okay okay and
uh so
this girl oh well these two brothers
they were set
to get married at the same venue with
different brides um
what do you mean oh yeah yeah yeah i
would do that i would do that in a
second
yeah so they were supposed to get
married on sunday
and one of the brothers his bride-to-be
um and and him like they would both pose
for
for the photos and like the wedding
reception festivities on saturday
and they received their guests and they
greeted everyone and everything right
but then on sunday
that's when navi naveen one of the
brothers
called nadeem nadeem uh he didn't show
up
he apparently got cold feet and it turns
out
it was because naveen's girlfriend not
the bride
threatened to throw in her life
if he would have gotten through with the
wedding saying that he's a player player
he had two girls yep she said that she
would drink poison
in front of the guests at his wedding if
he went through with the wedding he
saved the life so
yeah so dude that is some indian drama
[ __ ] right
now what i'm about to say is they're
crazy with like how far they'll take
them i will drink poison is like [ __ ]
shakespearean level no like
it's it's that they'll set themselves on
fire like though i saw
this one video circulating it was an
indian soap opera right
and then this girl she slipped she
knocked her head
she fell inside of a suitcase the
suitcase got zipped up
it went inside of a trunk and then it
left
and then and then this guy was like oh
my god i gotta go find her
but that's how he's like watching
indiana jones
maybe yeah cause that happens it's
pretty like no it was an indian it was
an indian soap opera
have you seen the indian soap opera
there's another one where like i think
she um
she she somehow gets wrapped up in a rug
and she she gets like a moving company
comes and takes him away
and it's like yeah there's all these
ridiculous things it's like
man this happens in india that's crazy
because that's all based on true life
no what i did see on twitter the other
day is uh this couple they got evicted
from their house
and they're literally like he's like
fighting the police because the police
came to the victim and they have like
all their kids and like the kids are
growing and stuff
and uh the dad and the wife set
themselves on fire to like
um to uh combat them getting evicted
and this is real this is real oh [ __ ] i
thought it was an indian soap opera no
maybe even indiana jones here yeah
yeah maybe the crazy [ __ ] that we see in
indian drama
is actually real like we're just over
like that [ __ ] will never happen dude
but then it's like in india it does
damn i don't know about this did they
live right here
unfortunately and what about the kids
they're just
they're crying damn come on man you
[ __ ] it up dude
twitter twitter it's a comedy channel
man
because in the last video we recorded
you're talking about
that's gladiator type [ __ ] that's
different people's heads exploding oh
what the [ __ ]
that was a movie dude you need to
sprinkle some comedy lime on your top
battle royale if it's on a video it's a
movie
yeah back to the story here so like i
said the girlfriend the sancha
she was she was saying that she would
drink poison in front of the guest so
then that's when naveen
was like oh [ __ ] let me go rescue my
girlfriend's life
and make sure she doesn't embarrass me
in front of all these guests there's a
question so then
you're raising your hand like hillary
then sorry
[Laughter]
so then that's when he got cold feet and
didn't attend the wedding
okay go was it an arranged marriage i
don't know okay well it seems like it
because
it seems like that it was based off the
two brothers parents
i mean it sounds like it so he didn't
want to marry her
but then it happened someone else has a
question oh yes
uh did did he end up going to her and
telling her what happened
i don't know how they found out because
the way they report it is just that he
just didn't show up like it seemed like
he got cold feet and he didn't show up
but is he blaming the girl or he really
didn't like it
i don't know all i know is that he
didn't show up to the wedding but the
the interesting part about this story
though
that's not even it is the fact that
after he wasn't there
to get married on sunday that's when the
bride was like
oh [ __ ] like i'm not going to get
married today like what the [ __ ] all
this money spent on
somebody would have some date so then
the family was like does anyone
want to marry her she's like up at the
altar and then so apparently one of the
guests volunteered was like
i'll marry her dude [ __ ] it's paid
for
yeah he's like oh [ __ ] that's that's it
for me i got a free bet
what is that i thought you were very
very picky what happened to your very
very picky nature
expensive oh i see as long as the
wedding's free dude that's like two
bitcoin man
a wedding yeah easily that's expensive
to them was it like a nice wedding or a
big one huh i get married for two bits
right now
bitcoin dude how many s is that
way too much 7000
i don't know no so this is the photo
that came with the article
and it doesn't have a caption so i don't
know if this is
the one that ran away the groom that ran
away or the one that married her
but let me see your personality so who
who they look so unhappy though why is
the guy standing like
crazy like this because he's like yo
this real life
yeah so apparently like both families
agreed with the wedding guest
to marry her and then that's i would
have been like oh my bad
my girlfriend's gonna kill herself i
gotta go well okay
they must know each other if they're
invited to the wedding
he's not a random but this looks like
say you just met yeah like i said i
don't know if this is the one
that got married or the one that ran
away does the chick have a say like if
the guy starts walking up to the chicken
no no
i don't want that one my grandma i don't
know the culture
i have no idea uh dated my grandpa
went on two or three dates before they
got married
so that was like the fourth time seeing
each other wow
and on that night she saw what a she saw
what a dick looks like
or she felt a dick she naturally just
know what to do with it
nah she just got [ __ ] and she was like
ooh
did she like it she didn't tell me this
she told my cousin this because they had
girl talk and then my cousin told me
and i was like ooh that's grandma
stories but tell me more because that's
weird
and then she was like i guess in my
grandma's words
she was like i didn't know what love
making was so i just let him do what he
wanted
and it was like ooh that's nice
do you ever text this cousin like at
three in the morning and go yo you got
any more grandma stories
no but my family's very open so she just
shared it i forgot what
we were talking about but we were
cracking the [ __ ] up
because like my grandma is like hella
crisp like it's it just doesn't fit the
brand right she's this like
[ __ ] conservative christian like
that's worse than mary magdalene
yeah she's like super like like holy
right
and then she told my cousins this
because i guess she
felt comfortable and then like they had
girl talk and i was like what the [ __ ]
that's crazy
wait so those were her grandkids she
told yeah
yeah yeah but but also my grandma's a
tomboy too that's why it's funny
like she never liked dressing up
she was always in the library always
doing like
you know boyish things in the library
yeah like [ __ ] hiking and adventuring
and then like doing library [ __ ] like a
[ __ ]
indiana jones so that's where you get it
from your grandma oh [ __ ] maybe
are the names different is like reverse
cowgirl reverse samurai
like different uh different names in
japan is it like that at all yeah
because i don't
he gave it to me sushi style yeah rolled
me up
i know style i told him omakase [ __ ]
that's stupid damn i i kind of want to
hear more about that
oh so the arranged marriage i um i was
asking her
man it's crazy weird because uh the way
that she explains it is like
because i asked her about dating in
japan when i was like a teen and i was
like so when you're a kid
like did dudes hit you up or like how
did it work and she goes well she's like
if you were a commoner
you go you could you could pretty much
marry freely for love or whatever and
i'm like wait you weren't
normal and she goes well we hadn't
arranged like my parents had to choose
everything
and i'm like how does that work like how
do you even talk to do you have a choice
and she goes yeah they they have a
choice of suitors right
so and then the families talk and then
they go oh your daughter might be well
with my
son or whatever and then they have a
third party who's like a chaperone
chaperone
who would come and uh hang out with them
to make sure that they don't do any
freaky [ __ ]
or whatever to make sure that you know
she stays a virgin or whatever dude
mormons do that [ __ ] too
yeah and i think christians do that even
too so the chaperone guys yeah but but
they're also like a guy
or a girl that me it's usually a guy or
something but they're they're a person
to help them talk because sometimes it's
easier
awkward when there's a third wheel yeah
and then they focus
on him and then they can bond that way
versus like
you know dating wasn't a normal thing
right so like if the parents aren't
there and they didn't want the parents
there
so it was like yeah and then the the guy
would report to
uh the parents how it was one weird
[ __ ] story
is one of the chaperones for my grandma
he was uh this guy named hideki tojo
which was the hitler of japan
what yeah she has a photo with them and
everything and i was like i know who
tojo is that's
crazy [ __ ] so that's the level of
family my grandma was in wow they hung
out with hitler
yeah and i was like i was like grandma
you know this guy was a horrible dude
like he
he killed like a lot of people in asia
and like he made japan like course
and she's like so yeah that's me and him
right there so fun at the dates he makes
the date so far
dude she was such a blind to the
realities of
what happened in the war yeah how did
she respond when you told her that she
was like
he was nice to me he's a nice guy he's
so good at comfortable
chaperone or the chaperone no no no she
never he was way older so he's way older
like
like so the chevron's usually like like
about the parents age or younger
right and then they ask a third party to
be
to go out on a date with them and they
ask him yeah crazy well they didn't know
he was a bad guy he was
so he took time off from killing people
two seconds before he was a bad guy
no it was before the it was before the
war like she got married like right
around the
like where it happened so he was a
military official he was just a
like a naval man or whatever i forgot
what it was a young adolf
yeah yeah well he he he yeah when he was
a good tipper at the bar
yeah right back in the day that is
pretty cool though
it's weird it's right it's history but
that's [ __ ] that's their culture too
and how
nonchalant she was about it yeah she was
very nonchalant about it like it's like
yeah
so her privilege and idea of normal was
so
beyond this world like so for example a
lot of my japanese
friends that their grandparents grew up
in japan they have
horror stories of the war like grave of
the fireflies have you guys seen that uh
like that film where the kid is like
hungry they have to eat leather and all
these things right
a lot of people have those kind of
stories my grandma on the other hand
she's like yeah we had it tough when
they started bombing our house
we had to go to the countryside estate
to run away
wow and then we had to live in the the
our our second house
so it's a it's a completely different
idea of reality
and then i didn't know this because like
i mean i was born and raised here and
whatever but like the older i got in the
story she told me
i was like oh crap like in the war
elevator broke
[Laughter]
they had one of the first few cars in
tokyo damn
and she was one of the first women to go
to uh university in japan
so that's why i was like what the [ __ ]
how come i never heard her
she's so special never heard of her one
[Music]
time
you